ok on va voir où vous en êtes mais
qu'elle vaut qu'on va faire lunardi view
vous pensez à quoi en ce moment là est
ce que je vais faire ce soir
les cfd naftogaz avec le matin quand
vous vous regardez dans la glace vous
pensez à quoi
c'est qu'ils suivent un homme n'a mais
qui ne s'émeut stakes je n'aime pas
faire les mêmes erreurs que dans le
passé mecha souhaite mais parce que ce
qui me concerne il faut toujours que je
travaille là dessus on peut retomber aux
chutes et est-ce qu'avec les opérations
quand vous vous regardez vous me
reconnaissez ce que vous êtes habitué à
ce changement physique je ne vois pas
vraiment ce qu'ils ont fait parce qu'ils
ont pris une petite partie de mon
oreille pour refaçonner mon nez cartes
in asia votre plus belle histoire
d'amour c'est là qu'elle milquet j'ai
compris la blague j'ai compris tu gagnes
quand l'amour c'est laquelle ça vous
regarde pas à quand est-ce que vous avez
pleuré pour la dernière fois
david l'autre soir dans ma chambre david
a dû venir me tenir par la main
vous étiez triste j'étais terrorisée
pourquoi je me suis bien amusé ici ça me
plaît ici
et ça fait pas mal d'années et son
agresseur et ça m'a rappelé beaucoup de
choses
je comprends vous changeriez quoi on
vous milk et si vous aviez une baguette
magique dure question en moi même des
mois j'aimerais apprendre à être seul
sans avoir besoin d'autrui
ça ce serait bien je pourrais rester
dans ma chambre jamais sortir et être à
l'aise
quel est le péché qui vous tente le plus
moche et vous la luxure agneaux fait la
luxure que pourriez-vous dire de plus
négatif sur vous j'ai des difficultés à
communiquer avec ma mère si votre vie
était art fair milk et qu'est-ce que
vous changeriez à les 11 premières
années quelle est l'insulté qui vous a
fait le plus mal
probablement lorsque ma femme m'a quitté
j'en avais honte aujourd'hui qui avez
vous le plus envie d'épater dans la vie
la brigade dieu 1
que feriez vous s'il vous restait 24
heures à vivre donc quoique - ouais
baiser ma femme et moi pareil
mais quelle est la dernière personne que
vous ayez eu envie de tuer toi si tu
insistes c'est quand je vois la boîte
parce que lorsque je discute de ça avec
un traître il m'a ordonné de crier à la
vierge marie et il m'a dit qu'il fallait
pas le faire
d'accord je n'ai pas le faire de toute
façon j'allais envoyer mes potes
j'avais déjà pensé au suicide non je
suis catholique je n'ai pas le droit de
me suicider et vous vous avez voulu vous
là ce que je prenais beaucoup de drogue
donc à un moment je voulais me suicider
et puis je n'ai pas fait aussi parce que
je pense que c'est pas bien ce que je
suis catholique aussi comme vous c'est
plus qui se droguent les catholiques 1,5
c c'est les hosties référence en
position qu'est ce que la vie vous a
appris à ne pas faire deux fois les
mêmes erreurs
comment aimeriez-vous mourir sans
souffrance vous voulez être enterrés ou
incinérés makolo sais je ne réponds pas
faut commander maintenant par la
fédération il ya 20 minutes d'attenté
dr dornach hockey pouvait mentir et
maintenant on l'a déjà enterré tellement
de fois les toute façon mickey est ce
que vous avez menti pendant cette
interview mais sauf que je suis vous
regretter d'être venu là ouais pourquoi
je préférais dans ma chambre
certes seuls je suis très content de
vous revoir et je vous trouve beaucoup
mieux que la première fois que je vous
ai vu en 87
vous êtes beaucoup plus sympathique à
l'époque j'étais un peu bad boy un peu
casse couille quoi j'aurais pas dit
c'est à l'époque dans le premier opus 21
pas merci et un cube héritage
dans un style là
m
rodez populaire le retour de l'été
boncourt